le sacle sacfice Sylrifice Sylis
renconrencone vétératre vétéraqe
encoreencorees séque les séquees
dangerdangerses misseuses missn.
qui noqui no attaquaus attaquan,
ils atils atquaient taquaient s.
Des e Des elosions,xplosions,
des dédes déagrationflagrations,
des endes enns explogins explof.
Je comJe come mêpte mê plusme ps
les foles fo que c'eis que c'e .
- C'es- C'esl'histoit l'histoi e
ébranlébranl transfoé, transfoé.
Le serLe sernt Davidgent David'x
a parta partipé àicipé àrois mis
en Afgen Afgnistan ahanistan acc
le Royle Roy 22e Régal 22e Rége,
entre entre 07 et 202007 et 20,e
revenirevenidans sa r dans sa s.
ChaqueChaqueois, il  fois, il cé
la morla mor souventt; souventce
de civde civs afghanils afghans.
DAVID DAVID UREUX,L'HEUREUX,ergé
ForcesForcesrmées ca armées cads
- On é- On éit làtait làour pror
la popla popation ciulation cile
que coque cote. Suûte. Suout les
et leset lesnfants,  enfants, it
les ciles cies quasibles quasin.
Dans nDans nre têotre tê, c'éta,
làlàon était, on étaitrêts prêtr
jusqu'jusqu' notreà notreerniere
pour ppour ptéger cerotéger ceg,
les prles préger jusotéger jusms
talibataliba, qui lens, qui le t
subir subir s atrocices atrocis.
(musiq(musiq sombre)ue sombre)
Quelq Quelqs semainues semaines
avant avant accidentl'accidental
qui lequi lea emports a emport..
- Au c- Au crs de seours de sets
en posen pos avancé,te avancé,et
L'HeurL'Heurx a ausseux a ausspu
plusieplusies de sesurs de sesa.
Des exDes exriences périences ns
dont idont ia encorel a encoreul
à pà pler aujoarler aujod'hui.u.
- Il y- Il yvait...  avait... it
malheumalheuux, maisreux, mais',
un goun got de vût de vgeance sr
les tales tabans quilibans qui'.
On s'eOn s'e dit : ist dit : ies
mort pmort pr rien, our rien, r,
il estil estas mort  pas mort u,
ChristChristn Duchesian Duches..
C'est C'est , le cheça, le cheDe
et l'aet l'audant madjudant matr
sont psont p morts pas morts pr.
On va On va ur faireleur fairee.
♪ ♪  ♪♪ ♪
- Davi- DaviL'Heureud L'Heureua,
dans sdans s bageses bagagesdess
intensintens, des soes, des sofs
refoulrefouls, physiées, physies
et psyet psyologiquechologiques,
et uneet unemmense d immense dr.
- Le p- Le pe, c'estire, c'estee
revenirevenià la r à la e norma.
Parce Parce e tu as que tu as u,
en arren arrère-gière-gût, loûtn
que tuque tus pas fi as pas fi .
Il y aIl y alque c quelque cse e
pas. Lpas. Lypervigi'hypervigint
encoreencoreà, pu là, pu ton niu
de strde strs et d'aess et d'aié
est anest anmalementormalementlé
pour upour u situatine situati e
que çaque çaevrait p devrait p .
Fait qFait q là, ue là, s dommar
ton syton syème nstème nveux set
tranqutranqulement, illement, s.
(musiq(musiq sombre)ue sombre)
(tir)(tir)
Oui,  Oui, le est pelle est p .
Mais cMais cst vraim'est vraimts
un jouun jou, làet, là.
Pour mPour m, c'est oi, c'est eé
zen. Pzen. Pdant ce endant ce m,
tu pentu pens à rses à rn d'aut,
puis çpuis çte permea te permed.
- Le s- Le sgent àergent à la re
a été a été rpris, lsurpris, l ,
de la de la pidité arapidité ace
les tales tabans ontlibans ontes
le conle conôle dtrôle dpays auu
cours cours s dernides dernires.
(tir)(tir)
Des soDes soenirs inuvenirs inns
fontrefonturface. surface.
- Et v- Et vlà!oilà!
Pour Pour tre frêtre frc, làancs
fâfâé en mauché en maut du résd.
C'est C'est nu me chvenu me chcs
ça vieça vie encore nt encore  .
Parce Parce 'encore qu'encore e,
c'est c'est s civilsles civilsut
le prile pri Encore x. Encore et
les feles fees et lemmes et leen
paientpaiente prix e le prix eA.
♪ ♪  ♪♪ ♪
- En 2- En 24, le se014, le seet
a prisa prisa retrai sa retrai..
Il a tIl a tté un chenté un chgt
de carde carère, rière, is a réé
que c'que c'ait impoétait impoi.
- Je v- Je vs l'essaais l'essar.
- Il s- Il sffrait douffrait dte
de strde strs post-tess post-tue
qui n'qui n'ait pas avait pas ce
été diété dinostiquéagnostiqué.
JOSÉJOSÉDUMAS,E DUMAS,
conjoiconjoie de Davnte de Dav x
- Dans- Danses pires ses pireso,
c'est c'est ûr qusûr quDavid, it
vraimevraime dans sant dans sau.
L'imagL'imagque j'ute que j'uti,
c'est c'est 'il y avqu'il y avtd
dans udans ubloc de n bloc de a,
dans udans uimmense n immense o.
Lui, iLui, iétait dal était da é
en Afgen Afgnistan ehanistan eo.
Moi, jMoi, jssayais 'essayais  i
parlerparlerpuis c'é, puis c'éi.
ça se ça se ndait parendait pa .
- Moi,- Moi,'ai été  j'ai été  .
Je suiJe suirevenu.s revenu.
Fait qFait q je trouue je trouve
que c'que c't un petest un pet x
à pà per pour ayer pour ut le bn
qu'on qu'on fait sura fait sure.
Puis, Puis,  n'a pason n'a pastà
pour rpour rn.ien.
- Mais- Maisà, ma là, matenant,,
justemjustemt, grâent, grâce au,
aux reaux reources qssources qié
cherchcherch, puis jer, puis jl,
ça l'aça l'anormémen énormémena.
Bien lBien l, mainà, mainnant,t,
il émeil émee, puis rge, puis  e
de... de... ir qu'ilvoir qu'il e
aprèaprès tout çs tout ç là, a,t
capablcapablde se ree de se rere
qu'il qu'il a d'autry a d'autr s
aprèaprès l'armés l'armé enfin!!
- Selo- Seloles spécn les spécl,
il peuil peus'écoulet s'écoulede
nombrenombrees annéeuses annéeat
que leque lesymptôs symptômes ne
manifemanifeent chezstent cheze.
David David Heureux,L'Heureux,u,
a comma commcé ses tencé ses tis
tout rtout remment, écemment, is
aprèaprès son res son reur au p.
Les i Les iges des mages des és
récentrécentsurvenuss survenusnn
pourrapourrant bien ient bien vr
le malle malui ronge qui rongeex
auesautresoldats q soldats q onu
cette cette erre de guerre de è.
- Aujo- Aujod'hui, jurd'hui, jp.
simplesimplent dire ment dire e.
malgrémalgrées résul les résulté
ce quice qui. ce ave... ce aveqs
vivre,vivre,utant ph autant phit
que psque pshologiquychologique.
j'en sj'en ss plus fors plus ft,
puis gpuis gnant. Paagnant. Paee
j'ai aj'ai aris de tppris de tt.
Puis, Puis, est pourc'est pourae
je souje souite que haite que ss
et meset mesrère frèred'armes st
cherchcherch ces reser ces resu,
pour qpour q ces genue ces genlà
puissepuisse les aidnt les aid..